foreign
[Music]
spirit is thus posited in the third
element in Universal self-consciousness
it is its community
the movement of the community as
self-consciousness that has
distinguished itself from its picture
thought is to make explicit what has
been implicitly established the dead
Divine man or human God is in himself
the universal self-consciousness this he
has to become explicitly for this
self-consciousness or since this
self-consciousness constitutes one side
of the antithesis and picture thought
that is the side of evil for which
natural existence and individual
self-consciousness count as Essence this
side which is pictured as independent
not yet as a moment has on account of
its independence to raise itself through
its own nature to Spirit that is it has
to exhibit in its own self the movement
of spirit
paragraph 781 is fairly short
particularly as we're coming off the
massive paragraph 780 and it begins with
a reference to what's going on in
paragraph
780 we get this spirit is thus positive
Gazette set down in the third element
and the term there is elementa so it's
just a cognit hegels deliberately using
that and we can say well what is this
third element the spirit is being placed
being put into this well he tells us in
Universal
self-consciousness and this is really
where we're going for the rest of the
religion section Olga minus zeb's Voice
sign right so self-consciousness has
been something absolutely Central
throughout the work so against the
self-consciousness section very
important for the religion section as we
know from the very beginning of the
religion section onward and then we have
um it being Universal Universal as
opposed to what particular einzelness as
we're going to talk about the singly
singular or single consciousness of the
as we're going to talk about it here the
human God the uh
person of Jesus Christ in in
Christianity
and so how is Spirit going to be put
down how is Spirit going to be
established because that's in this third
element of uh self-consciousness
Universal self-consciousness well
there's a lot of twists and turns to it
and the first one which big you know no
big surprise here it's Community Hegel
has been talking about Community for
quite a long time in the religion
section and if you've been reading ahead
you know that the community is going to
be where this religious
self-consciousness the universal
self-consciousness is actually not just
taking place but where it is working
itself out so
a lot going on here he says the movement
of the community as self-consciousness
and really we've got two distinct we
could call them movements if we want
that are paralleling each other when it
comes to this Universal
self-consciousness we've got the the
movement within the community the
bavagon right
going somewhere and this is going to be
a transition from the in itself for
implicit to something that is more
reflective as we're going to see and
then we have the other side of it we
could call this the the object but it's
also a subject that is being taken on
the dead Divine man or human God so this
movement has to be understood in this
way and then we're going to be trying to
get away
unsuccessfully at this point from
picture thinking or from imagination
from representation however you want to
translate Force telling so he says the
movement of the community of
self-consciousness that has
distinguished itself set itself apart
from its picture thought right so going
back a little bit further not just in
780 but before that we've got this
dialectic taking place within the
community the religious community
religion is working through four
stalingen right through images
representations these could be verbal
these could also be you could say
encapsulated in rituals and in action
but it's also at the same time
transcending that
reflectively
spiritually uh there's going to be a
more there and this more had better not
just be some sort of Airy fairy
mysticism or good feeling it really
needs to be something that is
communicable but in a mode that goes
beyond foreshelling so coming back to
the text he says the movement of the
community as self-consciousness that has
distinguished itself from its picture
thought is to make explicit how forward
to bring in to bring in front of us or
bring in front of its members what was
only implicitly
established on Zeke right so anzique is
often translated as implicitly makes
good sense the on Zeke needs to be
brought to the the you know four
something and give now here implicitly
established anzic of warden East so
established yes but really more like
what has become what has taken place
behind the scenes without us realizing
it so there's something and this is
again looking forward again something
very important what has been only
implicitly Don now needs to be
explicitly done and what is he going to
talk about next the dead Divine man or
human God the goat like a Manchester
menchley could goat notice the chiasm
there the sort of X thing going on and
this is worth dwelling on So Divine man
like a mensch right we have human being
the humanity as what has Divinity
predicated of it and then in the other
case we have God as or the Divinity as
what has Humanity predicated of it and
these can't just be predicates and
subjects that are sort of separate from
each other they have to interpenetrate
each other in Christ and we've talked
about this quite a bit already but now
this needs to be for the community he
says that the dead Divine man or God is
in himself the universal
self-consciousness in himself on Zeke
right and that needs to be made uh
explicit now for this
self-consciousness what
self-consciousness the universal
self-consciousness which is both that of
the Divine man the Divine man needs to
realize himself even in his death as
um you know this this Universal
self-consciousness but it needs to be
in for through carried on by the
community after this person's death even
if there is a resurrection it has to be
continued on after he exits the scene
uh church has to be established a
community has to be established so he
goes on and he says sense this
self-consciousness
constitutes one side of the antithesis
in picture thought right so now we've
got
picture thinking going on and you know
lots of discussion of that in the
previous paragraphs uh one side of the
antithesis the antithesis in this case
is literally a contradiction a giganzots
right the strongest form of being
opposed that we could have it's not just
that gagan gazettes it's you know gag
and zots right and what is this polarity
what is this side this side of the
antithesis the side of evil of Buddhism
for which he says natural existence so
naturally because dazine and
um individual self-consciousness now
this is interesting because it is eins
on the individual but it's not actually
self-consciousness is the term there
it's food
um which you know is that distinct from
or different from self-consciousness I
mean self-consciousness is being for
itself who is Exon being in relation to
another reflecting on oneself so it's
not a bad fit but it is a curious
translation Choice and then he says that
these natural existence and individual
self-consciousness
count as Essence as these as that which
is
centrally important right
then he goes on and he says this side
which is pictured as independent
not yet a moment has on account of the
independence this state of being
independent subject height to raise
itself through its own nature to Spirit
it has to establish in its own self the
movement of spirits and you know the
movement of spirit this spirit posited
in the third element is the community so
we have to have a movement from the
individual self-consciousness a
self-consciousness which could be that
of the Dead Divine man or could be that
of any individual worshiper or a
Community member into the community
understanding oneself not as lost in a
community but as an individual within a
community so that's what's going on here
in paragraph 781.
this self-consciousness is Natural
Spirit the self has to withdraw from
this natural existence and Retreat into
itself which would mean to become evil
but this side is already in itself evil
its withdrawal into itself consists
therefore in convincing itself that
natural existence is evil for the
Consciousness that thinks and pictures
the world has actually become and is
evil and the propitiation of the
absolute being was a real event but in
self-consciousness as such what is thus
pictured as happening as an event has as
regards its form the significance only
of a suspended moment for the self is
the negative and hence a knowing and
knowing that is a pure act within
Consciousness itself
this moment of the negative must
likewise Express itself in the content
that is to say a sense absolute being is
already reconciled with itself in itself
and is a spiritual unity in which the
parts of the picture thought are
suspended or moments what is expressed
in the content is that each part of the
picture thought here receives the
opposite meaning to what it had before
each meaning thereby completes itself in
the other and only through this
self-completion is the content a
spiritual one
since the determinantness is just as
much its opposite unity and otherness
that is the spiritual relationship is an
accomplished fact just as the opposite
meanings were United previously for us
or in themselves and even the abstract
forms of the same and not the same of
identity and non-identity we're reduced
to moments
paragraph 782 is going to follow up on
the key distinction that hegel's making
in this religion section between the
form of picture thinking and the way
that the self-consciousness understands
itself through that and the let's call
it a true perspective or true word
perspective of absolute being absolute
division in this case so you know what
is the absolute being if we're looking
back at the previous paragraph it's
going to be this Universal
self-consciousness which we find in the
dead God man and in the community and
how do we get the individual
reincorporated into that that is going
to be the key to this movement so he
says what we're talking about here is
natural Spirits Geist in the natural
form right or we could say understood in
this perspective so what is going on
with this we've got natural existence
not to leak kite it's not uh naturist
dazine or anything like that but the
state of being a natural uh
thing something that is in the world as
we're going to see a world that turns
out to be construed as evil and so
the movement of this Natural Spirit at
this place he says the self the zelps
has to do two things it has to withdraw
from this natural existence and you know
it's a little bit more active than just
withdrawing Zeke zuruk zuzian right so
zuruk means back to or going backwards
in a certain way and then Z and to to
draw to pull to pull itself out of this
natural existence and what we're going
to see is there's really two different
kinds of natural existence being
thought of here in this and then what
else is it supposed to do to retreat
into itself in Zeke through Gan now this
in Zeke again we have encountered this
before in this section right so that is
hearkening back to all of those
paragraphs and we should be thinking of
of that movement as well so the the self
withdraws itself from a let's call it
merely natural existence but it doesn't
withdraw itself completely from natural
existence we could say there's there's
natural existence lowercase n and then
there's natural existence let's call it
N squared right and this is still
something bad so the attempt to go into
itself away from its let's call it
animal existence into a distinctively
human individualized existence marks it
as evil as Biza right so he says this
side is already in itself evil right so
we've got two sides here natural
existence the self and the self has now
made itself more evil it's withdrawal
into itself he says consists in
convincing itself
right to uh tell itself to construct a
narrative in which it itself its natural
existence is evil and then he says for
the Consciousness that thinks in
pictures so now we're not just talking
about the individual but a horizon a
perspective the the uh Consciousness
that thinks and pictures the world has
actually become and is evil
and so it thinks of the propitiation of
the Divine being what what propitiation
are we talking about here a sacrifice to
make things right
okay what sacrifice is that the
Incarnation and then the uh you know
torture and death and in effect the
social destruction
of this Jesus human God person right so
that is supposed to like make things
right but you know does it really make
things right he says the world has
become evil the propitiation was a real
event that's being pictured as a real
event and now Hegel is not denying that
within history there was an individual
name Jesus recognized as the Christ the
anointed one who was crucified died was
buried or any of that sort of thing
right he's he's not calling that into
question and uh saying oh it's just
mythology or anything like that but he's
interested in the meaning
the meaning for history
of this event is it real in the sense of
being the truest story or is this just
interesting picture thinking or
representation that we have to unpack
so he says in self-consciousness is such
in the absolute being from the
perspective of the it's not being
brought up here but from the perspective
of conceptual thinking within the
religious community as opposed to
picture thinking within the religious
community we have self-consciousness as
such uh he he goes on he says what is
thus pictured is happening as an event
something that's happening right has as
regards its form the significance only
of a suspended moment so if the forms of
picture thinking are suspended moments
this is language that we've seen before
or superseded because the term there is
taking place here and these are moments
rather than things existing fully with
all other meaning on their own
so he goes on and he says
[Music]
um
here we go uh the the self is the
negative negative right and hence a
knowing now why would the negative be uh
knowing well because that's part of how
we we make sense of things as
creatures as beings that supersede the
world and its representational
contents right so this in here knowing
and the knowing interestingly Hegel is
going to say is a pure act I am the
highness
to this acting right so this isn't just
like a speculative sitting back uh you
know contemplating this is an activity
this is agency as well and so he goes on
and says this moment of the negative
must likewise Express itself in the
content
and what is that going to mean well he
goes on and he says
since absolute being absolute division
is already
reconciled with itself there is a
Reconciliation that has taken place in
history in spirit without us necessarily
knowing about it we might be stuck here
in picture thinking right but something
has been going on uh if only implicitly
now it needs to be brought into explicit
right in front of us you know sort of an
invitation join in the community he says
um
the moment of the negative must Express
itself in the content absolute being is
reconciled with itself in itself and is
a spiritual unity in which the parts
of the picture thought are suspended or
are moments okay so you know all of this
is not just simply false
but it's not complete it's to use a a
term that Hegel used a lot earlier in
the phenomenology one-sided right and
what we need is something that
incorporates and sublates all of these
moments that otherwise could be isolated
against each other and lose their Fuller
meaning so he goes on and he says
what is expressed in the content
in the content from the absolute
perspective is that each part of the
picture thought here
receives
the opposite or opposed meaning and
gagan gazette's
explicitly talking about meaning here
right a significance is another way of
making sense of it what it should be
translated into for us so every bit of
this is connected to some sort of
opposed and gagan because that's set in
opposition to it bit of meaning as well
so the self here is opposed to its other
in the field of representation
what does that mean that means that a
completion a full ending can take place
for these elements or these aspects or
these moments of picture thinking it
doesn't happen in picture thinking it
happens in absolute being in
self-consciousness as such in knowing
that is pure act in the community as
we're proceeding through so he says each
meaning
completes itself or is brought to
fruition is another way of thinking
about it in the other and only through
this self-completion is the content a
spiritual a geistiga one right that
takes the picture thinking and makes it
more it introduces a Transcendent
Surplus to it which is not going to be
found within the picture thinking itself
right it can only be gestured at by the
picture thinking and he says
since the determinantness the stint
height is just as much its opposite
unity in otherness the spiritual
relationship is an accomplished fact
once again we see Hegel revealing his
hand saying yeah this has already
happened now we need to make it
happen for us and the way that we
realize that this is for us is through
knowing that is also at the same time an
act we bring ourselves through
realization into that
community of absolute being the
spiritual community and so he says just
as the opposite meanings were United
previously for us or in themselves
and now notice what he's saying here
this goes back to the previous
paragraphs where we realize that these
very metaphysical
determinations you know to use this term
you know it again of the same and not
the same of identity and non-identity
these are themselves
moments now we've got two different
kinds of or perhaps even more than two
different kinds of picture thinking
going on we've got the picture thinking
that plays around with abstract Concepts
but is not yet the the you know the
concept itself
um grasping things conceptually we also
have the narrative in religion of the
you know extrication of the self from
nature still remaining within nature
being evil the world being evil the
world being reconciled to God through
the propitiation of the Divine being by
God himself becoming incarnate and dying
and all of these things connected
together we could talk about the Journey
of the self as well all of these are
moments
within something that exceeds
representation or picture thinking and
it can only happen interestingly enough
this is where we'll we'll close not
something that Hagel is actually saying
at this point uh but he has brought this
up before it can only happen within the
Matrix of a community not just some
isolated thinker going off by themselves
not just some hermit not just some
Mystic it happens through taking what is
you know has meanings and and pictures
and images and narratives and bringing
it into a higher level of reason or
Spirit here in the consummate religion